put it in context to for us this is a a
huge victory for Fabby again I mean it's
just
crazy for Fabby it's just a fantastic
year maybe one of the one of the best
year not the best year of his career but
U
he and I think maybe this is part of the
reason why he's playing so well he
doesn't actually need it anymore he is
more or less assured of winning the
grand chest tour he needed to play okay
he didn't really need to win the
tournament he need to play fine and he
already has qualified for uh for the
candidates so he is pretty much you know
free to roam here free to express
himself whereas half of half of the
field are still scrambling to qualify
for the candidates so for them it's a
lot more important and perhaps there is
more pressure on them and specifically
like on Wesley and and Anish who are uh
locked in that race for for the final
spot